all right Roger the CEO of the
ratchetness yoga
comes to it today with with kind of a
brief he could have spoken on theology
because he has an extraordinarily
theological mind and his written and
thought a great deal about that or he
could have talked about the sociology
but the portfolio we asked him to pick
up was practices right best experiences
what have we learned about youth
ministry and how could we do better than
Roger Nishioka who has time in grade as
a youth minister growing up in
congregational and Presbyterian churches
14 years as the National Director of
ministries adolescence and youth for the
PC USA and has been teaching on this
something five different courses at
Columbia Theological Seminary in Decatur
Georgia just to whet your appetite and
set you up for what he must be
accountable to answer questions on since
he wrote books about it he asked because
he has my chapter elevate the
expectations soul Rogers works it out
Rogers working on at church question
mark ministry with young people and he
is revising a very well-received book
roots of who we are and as sowing the
seeds and exploration of faith
development in adolescence so there's
much much fruit that you bring us these
are party favors from Roger I'm gonna
pass this ball around if you did not get
your party thank you sir
hey friends we'll be with you okay so I
know yeah human flourishing
thank you dr. wolf up so I know that I'm
gonna use the screen and I was reminded
by Greta knows there are some sight line
issues and if you can't hear me at a
certain point then you need to signal to
me as well but I'm gonna use the screen
at least to an extent for our
conversation of so ministries young
people conversation with youth ministry
leaders skip said this I really am I've
been charged with looking at practical
application for youth ministry I teach
in the practical theology area at
Columbia seminary it's entirely possible
to be practical and Theological at the
same time so within that I'm a professor
of Christian education my specialization
is used in an adult ministry we are
blessed at Columbia to have two
full-time professors in Christian
education my colleague Kathy Dawson who
is amazing teaches me things everyday
professionalisation is early childhood
and children I pick up using and adults
and then together we cover the adult
spectrum in Christian education and the
practical theology area is all kinds of
fields like the doing of ministry
preaching pastoral care worship pastoral
theology etc evangelism church growth
yeah a presbyterian school has an
evangelism professor kind of a illusion
anyway so
and he came to us from the African
Methodist Episcopal Zion it's hurts yeah
because we couldn't find a presbyterian
nobody Vangelis so I'm delighted to be
with you I'm tremendously honored um
gift a gift for 2012 gift for 2012
people trust you with the precious
commodity what is it children and more
importantly right now their time time
2012 the precious commodity is time
certainly as children you're exactly
right thank you for saying that and for
young people but precious commodity even
for our young people is their time right
okay more precious than gold and giving
even given the world markets more
precious than Facebook stock which will
soon make Mark Zuckerberg the most
wealthiest person in the history of
humankind etc is people's time so a folk
gift you with their time your job is to
nice nice treat it with respect and
integrity and the gift of the Holy
Spirit as it is so I'm grateful for your
time I'm yeah of amazed with skip also I
was thinking oh nice lunch fifteen
sixteen people on a table of a nice
conversation and then I wrote to Greta
and said what are we talking about and
she said oh about a hundred people will
show up I thought really these people
need to get a life but I am honored that
you're here especially talking about
young people which is my passion and my
love so let's pray together please so we
give you thanks O God for the gifts that
you give to us not only your time but
also your body through your son Jesus
Christ with whom we are journeying yet
once again to Jerusalem in these days we
give you thanks O God for your gift of
your Holy Spirit who sustains us even in
the moments when we do not know or
acknowledge or recognize that your
spirit is moving for us and through us
sometimes perhaps in spite of us yet
your spirit moves and she blows through
our lives and sustains us all indeed
your whole creation we thank you for you
O God mother and father of us all who
made us in your own image even the image
of an early adolescent middle school
or even the image of a junior in high
school even the image of young adults
even the image of an old one and a
newborn so we give you thanks O God for
the ways you image around us your being
indeed your whole creation help us to be
so attentive to you that we see you in
every place in which we are venturing in
these days and God's people say Amen so
my conversation is it really is a
conversation with youth ministry leaders
you're doing this beautifully already my
own tradition you can tell perhaps you
can't but you can
I'll tell you right now is an Asian
American tradition I come from a
japanese-american tradition
born and raised in Honolulu and like the
president I have a birth certificate and
it's real anyway
I live in the state of Georgia so that's
an issue so in my own tradition I
realized that I am a commission seeking
person it's what I've been raised with
as an Asian American those of you who
are Asian Americans in this room you are
in that same stream you know this that
you don't participate until you've been
invited into the conversation so I'm
inviting you into the conversation okay
I was grew up in Honolulu and then was
called to Seattle where I was living for
a while with my folks went to
undergraduates high school etc went to
seminary in Chicago graduate school PhD
worked there as well and then now I'm
teaching in a place called Decatur
Georgia Atlanta which is a great place
to be at Columbia seminary what I've
discovered is not all cultures are
permission seeking cultures but I'm
trying to issue permission at this point
for the conversation I'm preaching in
one of our African American historic
african-american congregations outside
of Atlanta discovered that that by and
large the African American culture in
worship doesn't expect permission
it's granted already so now isn't
McCormick seminary I was taking
preaching class and one of my professors
talked about how a great tool in
preaching is the rhetorical question
what's a rhetorical question nicely done
dr. Richard says a question that you
asked expecting no answer and this comes
from an Anglo older white presbyterian
professor he says these are effective
tools and preaching these days I was an
historic african-american congregation
outside of Atlanta I had a great
rhetorical question so what is the Word
of God for us today thinking dang that
is a great rhetorical question I misread
my context I wasn't in a white church I
wasn't in an Asian American congregation
I was in a historic black church woman
in the back lovely hat lord it out well
honey if you don't know then why you up
there
and I wish I could say that I responded
really nicely but I'll tell you I was
shocked
well I I know I'm preaching I've got a
sermon but oh that that was rhetorical
you you you shouldn't answer and she
said well baby in this church if you
don't want to answers don't ask no
questions
and I said oh yeah no no more questions
bad asking questions so I'm inviting a
conversation this day really truly okay
so a conversations being invited
permissions being given for those of you
who need that from your particular
context your particular culture those of
you who do not thanks be to God for you
okay so I hope to have a conversation
about you about just the nature of
ministry I'm line out some things with
you and then we'll see where we go so
you have one of these right okay
practice of youth ministry okay if you
would please take it out because of the
space I realize that this is difficult
for us but if you wouldn't mind
stand up please if you would you you
probably can't move very well but your
goal is to find somebody around you to
you agree on a number numbers one
through on the very back is 20 thank you
well I'm Bruce numbers 1 through 20 you
agree on a number and you answer it
together please go to that number
whatever it is just choose one and then
do that with a couple other people
around you as much as you possibly can
ready go
I would say the second thing is
all right I've got aging parents and I
am one of four boys which is nice but I
live in Atlanta
okay sit down sit down Lucy conversation
sound
conversation hey thank you for that so
um in the practice of youth ministry
that's called something called group
building right okay
I teach a class at comely a seminary
titled trying to sit out guide make make
eyes at me with if I'm too much in the
screen I teach a class on a group
building and Faith Formation at Columbia
seminary everybody's picking up on this
corporations are picking up on this
that's the whole idea of group nests and
group building is essential even
corporations are realizing for workers
to get together and function in the same
way okay the Church of Jesus Christ is
no different amen
and young people are no different
especially I want to argue that young
people are especially in need in these
days of group building as well so there
is bad group building there are bad
resources out there that are stupid
okay and some of you are buying them so
stop it okay but I want to talk about
what good group people building then is
in good group building I think every
person's included alright so in this
activity who is included everyone even
you who are introverts whom the Lord
made also you were included okay
extroverts you get your energy from
other people introverts you get your
energy from from within yourselves
that's not a bad thing what
a continent is energy from diet coke
thank you very much
it's energy comes from what's inside
yourself can't introverts exhibit great
extrovert skills yes they can just after
a while they have to go into a closet
and go okay literally okay one of my
best friends you would never know she's
an extrovert but after a Sunday morning
she goes home and she sleeps okay and
it's just gone
etc all right and I'll say hey let's go
see movies she goes no no I'm going home
I have to go home all right in good
group building every person's included
there are awful awful group building
activities and books that they're
selling to you and to me
Episcopalians Methodists Presbyterians
Baptists we love to buy these books UCC
folks you buy all these books etc that
tell young people then you are out you
you play a group activity and if you
don't do it right you're out that
doesn't qualify okay because you tell me
a 13 year old boy gets out then he gets
bored then he gets destructive that's
not his fault that's the nature of
creation okay
then you yell at him because he broke
something okay I want to argue that's
whose fault it's your fault because you
constructed it that way okay I don't
mind
elimination activities I just want every
opportunity for the kid to get back in
alright because there are elimination
things where you get out and then you
have to get tagged to get back in I love
that okay so no one stays out all the
time in good group building every
person's included number two the leader
of models and participates I was just
with a group of 200 high schoolers in
Northeast Georgia this past weekend
speaking to them and pretty much during
all of the group building activities
where were my adults they were on the
edge
tell me again they were talking to each
other on the edge of the room drinking
coffee and it was bad coffee so there's
no excuse okay and I hate that all right
because you have a chance to model and
participate do you have to be able to do
what you're asking them to do you know
nicely done
so one of my best experiences of a youth
ministry leader was a paraplegic who's
63 years old her name is Shirley and she
led us in recreation upstate autumn
outside of Milwaukee at a conference
center I remember it was wet that spring
we had to take all of these eight-by-ten
huge plywood sheets and lie them end to
end at the end of the field so that
Shirley could roll up and down with her
megaphone and give us instructions okay
could she do what she was asking us to
do
no but if there was a miraculous healing
which is entirely possible by the grace
of God amen if I asked any kid on that
field 400 kids on that field all
Presbyterian kids if I said to them do
you think if there was a miraculous
healing that surely in a moment would be
out of her wheelchair on this field
every single kid would have said what in
a moment she'd be out okay so you model
and you participate I'm third idea is
that in good group building each
person's right to pass is preserved did
I give you the right to pass no I did
not okay so you have to decide if you're
going to give young
people the right to pass because if you
give it guess what they'll take it and
you'll say notice what's the last 12
minutes okay and everyone just passed
and then you say oh come on you guys
just do it okay
and then they're like okay cool we were
just testing to see if you are worth
your word do you ever you have any
integrity about you at all oh good you
don't so you go into this whole category
of other adults in our lives who have no
integrity about them you you say to us
don't do it as I do do as I say well
thank you that's an operative philosophy
of life and we understand that and so
now we put you over in that category
okay if you give the right to pass to
adolescence be ready because they mate
take it and then what do you do live
with it nicely done you then you go on
to the next thing and say okay well
let's try this okay um I didn't give you
the right to pass so that you were
making this you make the decision you
choose as a group leader whether you
give them the right to pass i'm hunching
that pretty much in these 20 questions
there are some harder ones than there
was some Elizabeth and I did a harder
one listen but then I did um sources of
anxiety for the future number what
number was that do you remember I can't
remember three there was some harder
ones and easier ones but what a kid
could do with a booklet like this is the
kid could decide what yeah I don't want
to do that one and go to a safer one etc
so that is a built-in to an extent but I
think the right to pass is important you
decide if you can give it or not to be
honest when I work with middle schoolers
I often don't give them the right to
pass because my middle schoolers chances
are may not know one of my best friends
in ministry amazing amazing pastor see
mrs. Williams Reverend Williams she says
to her sixth graders they said mrs.
Williams we don't want to do this
because baby you don't know what you
want
I'll tell you what you want you want to
follow Jesus that what you want
like okay so she doesn't entertain
because maybe you're in sixth grade you
don't know what you want you don't know
what you want you want to follow Jesus
that's what you want okay and then they
do whatever she tells them to do
okay so sometimes my early adolescence I
don't give them the right to pass as I
know they don't know what they want they
just don't know okay please Oh nicely
done it's a great question tell me your
name
Bruce ask is their way to give them the
right but encourage them not to take the
right the answer is yes what's the way
there are several ways well what's one
way
okay we're still we're still sorry in
the diet coke trajectory there yeah um
the answer was candy yes you can bribe
them that's true I want to argue when
leaders model and participates they want
to put than they want they don't want to
pass because part of it is they want to
see what you do okay
if leaders truly model and participate
and they realize oh I'll be darned
so you're gonna actually be doing this
with us then often because you've
modeled it they won't pass because
they'll say this could be fun and
besides we get to watch Bruce do it okay
and be entertained and it'll be up on
Facebook in a few moments okay so it's a
great question yes there are ways and I
think the most critical thing in group
bullying theory is what the leadership
does if everyone's in it then people
tend not to pass because safety issues
and trust issues rise they feel like
okay if I'm gonna be embarrassed guess
what we're all gonna be embarrassed and
you're gonna be most embarrassed because
you look stupid pastor doing this okay
thank you for asking the group is built
at know one person's expense there are
actually resources out there that say
what you do is you pick on one kid
everyone laughs at that kid and the
group building happens isn't that lovely
theologically you tell me when in the
kingdom of God when in the random of God
did Jesus decide the way that's best to
build the whole body of Christ is to
pick on one person and make them
ostracized it doesn't hold theologically
okay so the group builds is built at
know one person's expense my last one
this is my catch-all um the group
building honors the presence of the Holy
Spirit Mike at all on this is that's why
I don't do food games which makes me sad
cuz I love food games I love playing
with food I love having young people
play with food I think it's hilarious
what is my problem with playing with
food it gets messy thank you that's true
what else
it is disrespectful of of our resources
and not everyone thank you say you say
it again amen not everyone has food to
eat and the the what happened to me was
I was at a conference center in Virginia
and we had this thing called the banana
relay okay and so we were invited up
into teams and the the but the banana is
a baton and you go through all these
different activities and the banana gets
passed from activity to activity at the
very end in order it will win okay the
leader has to eat the Banat by the end
of the activity the banana whet is
horrible okay and everyone's cheering
and eating and the bananas are brown and
mushy and people are spitting it out and
throwing it away etc and and and God is
totally messing with me it's just a
handful but it's like you know we only
have like 15 16 teams so just fifteen
sixteen bands this is not hard you know
this come on
there was a exchange student apparently
right there next to me from Costa Rica
dang stupid God okay
and she's clapping alright and she says
this is so much fun I love watching
Americans play with the food from my
country and like it's just 16 bananas
I'll give you money what why is this oh
oh I love this this is so great America
such a great country I'm like please
come on it's just 16 - it's ok ok
message to her was that which is a
staple of your country we get to play
with Americans can disrespect this and
there are people who are hungry around
us 25 percent of children in the United
States today will go hungry let alone
the entire world ok this is my catch-all
for all resources not wasting resources
so if you don't want to take these
little booklets which one of my students
bless her heart
stapled and cut out okay give it back to
me and she'll be glad ok but if you want
to take him home that's fine but all
have resources ok in group building
theory here's the idea in group building
theory group nests is achieved through a
minimum of 17 contact hours they've
quantified it they say it takes 17 hours
minimum Li for a group to be a group
your job is to build group nests among
the adolescents the young people in your
congregation in your parish that's your
job okay
group building theory says you don't get
group this until you've had 17 hours 17
contact hours all right here's the
theory the 17 contact hours they don't
have to be contiguous but they do have
to be continuous okay so it isn't 17
hours all attached it could be but it
doesn't have to be but it does have to
be 17 continuous hours which means that
every time the group meets five of you
or 15 of you or whatever it is
whenever the group meets the same people
have to be there otherwise you go back
to our number one okay so you get a
parent of a lovely sophomore who says to
you you know I would like Jennifer to go
but she keeps on saying she doesn't have
any friends in the youth group or a
church and you're like well that's odd
because Jennifer knows all these other
young people and she does what Jennifer
is saying to her mom and to you
vicariously is I don't have group nests
I don't have group nests okay this is
the shift and this is God's intention
this is how you know God has a great
sense of humor and about Oh 11 12 years
old God says to young people begin to
shift your primary allegiance from whom
parents to whom to peers at the same
time this is how you know God has great
sense of humor God says to parents this
is a really scary time hold on okay so
you have a lesson saying get away get
away in parents when I come back come
back and God's going this is so cool
okay so when you go to heaven you can
say what was up with that Lord but for
the time being that's the intention the
reason why it's the intention is because
when they're 33 they ought not to be
having their primary relationship with
you
so I must know 33 year-olds who are
still attached to their mothers and
fathers and it's not attractive okay it
doesn't happen very well on eharmony.com
it's not a good thing okay
who your best friends my mom and my dad
best friends in my life etc okay so
there's a whole shift going on they're
supposed to be more aligned to their
peers and they are to their parents at
this point that's God's intention so
you're trying to build 17 contact hours
for group nests group this is defined as
three ways group Namine x' person's
claim common rituals and norms that
there is a way of doing a way of being
that is common I can ask anybody in the
group what are some rituals what are
some norms ways of behaving one ways
living together and every person says
the same kinds of things not in the same
language but they get ideas of rituals
and norms a ritual keep in mind is any
activity that opens us to deeper meaning
a ritual is any activity that opens us
to deeper meaning not all activities are
rituals or ritualistic all right so
rituals and norms second major
qualification for group nests persons
share a common story and purpose
I can ask anybody in the group what's
the reason for your existence and
they'll be similar language not
identical but similar language evil will
say this is why we're doing this is what
we're about
etc the common story there's a narrative
that floats around that young people
share after a point of group Ness
corporations have picked up on this
that's why corporations pay tons of
money to send teams of workers to go out
to these conference centers and do group
building activities exact same kinds of
things you and I are doing in youth
ministry only they pay twenty seven
thousand dollars a weekend to do this
okay because they realize when those
people together have this common rituals
and norms and share a common story and
purpose they function better
they work more effectively and they are
more productive for the corporation we
are no different all right I'm arguing
that adolescents in these 17 hours it's
interesting the research is actually
pushing the hours up 10 years ago it was
14 2012 it's now 17 hours why is it
getting higher ah nicely done electronic
distractions a social technology stuff
is huge that's true distractions in
general well done
other reasons why it's getting higher ah
Elizabeth says they don't know how to do
community your exam sorry Christine says
we don't the community and we're exactly
right well the loss of community in
America Robert Putnam and others etc
please members of various groups so we
sort of dip in various groups and never
nest or land in one nicely done other
other reasons other games are in town
other options available to us
well then choices have exploded
exponentially other major issue there is
a healthy dose of skepticism and
cynicism among adolescents about any
group why why are they more skeptical
and cynical before bid invest in a group
in these days ah nice that's a great
statement every group seems to want
something from them that's true
individualism that's nice the rise of
this it's all about me which fits lovely
in some limited with egocentrism which
it said we're adolescents are so it's
all about me exactly in
nice nice that's beautifully well said a
lack of trust in institutions Authority
etc in a 24/7 news cycle we know think
we know more things now about people
that we never wanted to know okay and so
they're saying that they don't trust
necessarily any group because they've
watched people betray trust over and
over and over again whether it's a
priest whether it's a athlete or a
politician or a schoolteacher or
whomever we watch people betray trust
over and over again this skepticism this
mistrust the cynicism is throughout the
entire culture of the entire society so
it's taking longer to get to group nests
and the group exhibits the ability to
maintain its identity in the midst of a
dialectical and sorry dialectical
challenges sorry oh I should have been
that bitter languages and dialectical
challenges so the great dialectic okay
what's the great dialectic come on my
philosophers Hegelian dialectic what
starts with a nicely ends up their
thesis and leads to nicely done that's
the dialectic okay a thesis an opposing
idea leads to a new creation a new way
of thinking a new way of being
that's a dialectic okay one of my
faculty members honorably retired Walter
Brueggemann who wrote most of the Old
Testament because he was around man
anyway
Walter says the great dialectic he pulls
from a philosopher named Paul record
says the great dialectic throughout all
the scripture Old Testament and he
argues New Testament is an orientation
God's people an orientation
next to well yeah Thank You professor
disorientation leading to reorientation
Walter says that's the whole story of
the Bible people are in orientation cool
I get this then they're disoriented that
Golden Calf thing didn't work out very
well
odd okay
and then having to reorient okay Walter
says that's the dialectic here's the
challenge in this 21st century when you
get to that antithesis that
disorientation
most people will what leave exactly
they will opt out because this isn't fun
anymore
and this doesn't meaning my needs and
it's all about me okay
I was talking about this with one of my
pastoral care theology professor
colleagues dr. Pamela Cooper white who
is a great Episcopalian okay fine you
people huh great Episcopalian priest
anyway Cooper white was talking to me
and she was saying you know Roger what
amazing thing about marriage and Family
Therapy when you have a couple or a
family that's a major disorientation if
you can get them to reorientation that
family that marriage on the other side
of it is is stronger it is more
resilient is the pain there heck yeah
is the memory there oh yeah they're like
man you were stupid yeah I was stupid
okay but she said on the other side of
it when you get that family or that
couple to the other side of
disorientation to reorientation they are
like I'll be darned we are stronger than
I ever imagined that was bad but look
how we survived that that's the essence
of resilience there's a ton of money
right now being thrown in studies about
young people and resilience factors
called the resilience factor because
they're trying to figure out what makes
a kid be Raziel can we quantify
resilience in some way and this ability
to stand through this orientation and
this is to the other side that's an
amazing amazing place to be okay I would
add as theologians you and I by the
grace of God we end up on the other side
of disorientation to reorientation in
our relationship with each other with
God even possibly with the Church of
Jesus Christ is stronger pain is still
there memory is still there but this
ability to survive a dialectical
challenge is quite remarkable
so 17 hours not necessarily contiguous
but continuous so I've got a youth group
and we're gathering for an hour and a
half once a week we start in mid-august
when is it possible for me to get to 17
hours if everyone shows up every single
time early as possible November the
problem is you already see it coming
what happens people show up not show up
some of our adult leaders rotate and
change okay I totally get this I totally
get that you're trying to recruit
leaders and you're like you don't have
to come every time I know you're busy
you're traveling so just come when you
can okay
the problem is every single time that
group meets they're on our number one
okay in group building theory our one
one one one that gets really really old
fast
people get weary of our one there is no
ritual and norm there's no shared
history or purpose there's no sense of
being able to survive in the midst of a
dialectical challenge why should i
invest in this group
why should I be a part of this this
applies I'm convinced at church boards
and sessions and consistory 's and
committees unconvinced that this is
lived out in everything all time we
tried be a group okay so tell me how you
get in youth ministry to seventeen hours
as fast as possible
ah nice a lock-in literally a lock-in
okay but you're doing a lock-in and this
lovely parent comes to you and says oh I
know you this is really important but
hey Sean it has a soccer game tomorrow
morning
I can I can pick him up at 6:30 drop him
off later at 1:00 o'clock after he plays
a soccer game and cleans up that'll be
okay right and you say to her to the
well-meaning mom it's not gonna be okay
please
oh wow
lovely language whew golly also
guilt-ridden which as Asian American I
love it what what yeah nicely done
I totally get that is there for Roman
Catholics even better that's great stuff
exactly my parents growing up knew that
they could they could they could hit us
with a wooden because they're bad
parents they would spank us but they
wouldn't cuz they're bad parents they
would do the evil evil thing they would
use the D word what the D word is we're
so I hated that I was like please just
beat me okay like no Roger that's okay
we're just disappointed in you I'm like
okay can I just die right now please
instead of a no I think you're exactly
right please that's lovely yep that's it
tell me your name Peter Esther give you
the question Peter asked how do you
balance this requirement if you will
with with being a community at full of
grace
whereas in the other parts of their
lives if they miss a practice if they
miss a rehearsal they can't perform they
can't do the recital they can't play etc
but how about we be a grace filled
community Peter thank you I completely
support that and agree with you I want
to be a grace filled community what I do
say to my parents is on this weekend
we're trying I tell them this theory
this is not secret okay I tell my youth
group this theory at Central
Presbyterian Church Atlanta okay we're
trying 417 contact hours so I really
appreciate and everything else that we
do show up or don't show up but for this
fall retreat we're trying to build group
nests I need 17 hours
okay and when I tell the parent that
stepparent that then she realizes I
don't hate her I hate her kid I've got
actually a theological and pedagogical
framework for this okay we're trying to
get seventeen hours it's gotten to the
point a little bit spooky where I've got
my kids coming to me and saying hey what
hour are we on and I'll say I think
we're on our 11 and it feels like our 11
because we're still in our little of
individual groups okay cuz I've got 22
young people on a good night really
truly and I've got 17 high schools in
that 22 young people etc and so they
feel like yeah we're it feels like an
hour 11 because we're still not doing
this group nough stuff you talked about
I mean why young people know this and
they articulate it
I read then people say to their parents
I've got a missed practice because we're
trying for 17 hours this weekend
okay for the other weekends that we do
what they can come and go it's okay but
the cool thing is once I get group Ness
ah there it is they want to be there
because their friends are there because
they've experienced something that is
remarkable in their lives and they're
like no I I want to I want to be a part
of this this remarkable thing because
they're yearning for it why do you think
that vapid ridiculous sitcom friends was
the number-one sitcom among 15 year olds
every year that it ran and now in
syndication it's still popular it's not
just because a bunch of young adults get
to sleep around and live in to amazing
places in Manhattan with no jobs
it's because young people are looking at
these friends and they're like they have
witness I want that I yearn for that in
my life I don't have that I yearn for it
it is so attractive
it is so compelling I think the Lord
made us this way I really truly do so if
I could frame it theologically
theological answer why group nests it is
essential to faith formation it is the
very nature of God and we are the imago
Dei Latin for God is relationship
through the Trinity so we are created
for your relationship if we believe that
we are created in God's own image okay
and God's image God's very self is
relationship to God's own three and one
okay
then being created in God's image means
we are created for relationship we have
to be that we yearn for it
we are desperate for it because we are
created in God's own image and god
godself has Group nests in God who is
the mother and father of us all God who
is the son Jesus Christ and God who is
the Holy Spirit
it's a theological answer it isn't just
a cool thing to do it isn't just fun it
doesn't just get allegiance or power
Andy root you had earlier talking to you
about a new way of thinking about
relating etc okay I'm arguing that the
whole idea of this group is deeply
theological because it is the nature of
God and we are created in God's image
now what I'm worried about is to be
honest with you I think the 17 hours is
gonna go higher in the years to come I
really do this indication of that
already among this generation please
yes precisely precisely you were exactly
yep yep thank you you you named it you
named it beautifully you're exactly
right please Emily yep yep yep yeah yeah
exactly exactly exactly exactly exactly
what is thank you that you're testifying
you're exactly right what's amazing to
me is when when the young people again
have achieved this among themselves okay
that sets that whole discourse aside
because the question isn't being asked
anymore who's going to show up because
they know group nough swill happen it's
already happened and they're gonna be
there with their friends etc I would say
the body of Christ and so it doesn't it
doesn't matter to them who's there and
who's not there what matters is that
it's it's taking place and I want to be
a part of it please
yes yes yes exactly right okay so think
it's telling your name
Donna asked a brilliant question Donna
you're exactly right
I honestly I've decided in my ministry
to give up on it
I can't convince my parents enough okay
this is valuable it's it's not gonna
carry the same weight on their resume on
their kids resume when they apply to an
Ivy League school okay that starts with
a why it's so but what changes the whole
conversation is when the kids themselves
make the decision because suddenly the
parents saying but honey you need to go
to soccer practice and the kid says
actually thanks mom but I need to be at
youth group this weekend because we're
doing this this and this and this okay
I've discovered and Donna you're on it
thank you for asking when I tried to do
the opposite way and get parents
convinced first to make their kids come
okay then then I was lost when the kid
says it's called it's called the
fast-food syndrome of church growth that
when people are looking for a church
home and parents come in with a kid an
adolescent and the parents are looking
at this church and they're like oh man I
don't know this preacher you know the
music and it's sort of a hard place to
get to the parkings not great the
theology could be not what we're looking
for etcetera their twelve-year-old turns
to them and says this is a pretty good
Church I think I want to come here guess
what they stay okay it's called fast
food syndrome of church growth because
McDonald's did you know this McDonald's
Taco Bell etc Burger King Oh Wendy's by
the way is number two in the world just
overtook Burger King yesterday as
fast-food
Wendy's etc they lose money on their
Happy Meal stuff did you know that the
reason why they do this they know if
they get the kid they get they get the
car they get the parents okay it's
called the fast-food syndrome of Church
gross all right if I can get that kid to
say this
a pretty cool church I'd like to come
here then the parents are like okay cool
we'll come here it's the same phenomenon
that I'm watching with young people that
if they say this is worth my while and
my time even though the parents saying
oh but honey you committed to this and
this and this they're like mom dad this
actually is more important to me and
then you begin to talk about language
around that and they say things like
because they're really really good at
this this has to do with my eternal
salvation no motivation whatsoever I
know I know but no thank you seriously
thank you it's a great question I've
given up on trying to rationalize with
parents because I'm not going to get
there and I want to respect them as well
but when a kid says it it changes the
whole discourse please powerful man sure
sure sure
Oh colored yeah yeah yeah it totally is
yes oh I'm sure there is thank you for
saying that you're exactly right tell me
your names Lee says and did you get this
Lee talks about Thank You Lee talks
about one mission trip the first night
was the first night right a young woman
went through almost a three-hour period
like a panic attack really and she was
texting home and calling home and saying
please forgive me because I can't stay
who's gonna get me and you said to the
parents no just wait I know they were
and because in the day and age okay
that's called what helicopter parents
because they hover so they think she
needs me again so I'm gonna rescue okay
etc what I need is parent is free to say
to the parents her health is not in
danger okay we're right here I've got
911 on speed dial she'll be okay what I
need you to do is just give me some time
just wait okay because what the kid is
experiencing is disorientation on the
other side of it she gets to and she
realizes that she herself is stronger
resilient because at some point she's
gonna go off to school or get married or
end up on her own living somewhere and
she if she tries to call then and
parents come and rescue then the
patterns already been set and it's
dangerous but as long as she's in a safe
place and you can assure the parents
she's okay then I think you're exactly
right
okay I need to move on because I'm
watching time I'm sorry I want to finish
up with this
if I look at the 21st century youth
ministry okay this is required reading
for all of our first-year students at
Columbia seminary post modern pilgrims
lens suite teaches a drew Divinity
School really really good guy lives in
the San Juan Islands in Seattle I don't
get the commute thing but anyway um he
would he's written a book called
postmodern pilgrims and I'm pulling a
chapter from him sweets says the 21st
century Church must be for things as a
presbyterian I love this because it's an
acronym experiential participatory
imagistic that's actually my language
not his and communal as a scholar you
get to adapt people's ideas and then
sort of think it's your own as an
illusion um experiential participatory
imagistic communal if I could line this
out what I want to do is I want you to
think about your youth ministry program
your ministry with young people whatever
it is as experiential as participatory
as imagistic and communal okay I think
sweets on to it I think he gets it I
think the nature of the church in the
21st century has to be thinking about
these four things so if you've been to
is gonna come if you've been to
Disneyland or Disney World I'm you
seeing this hopefully it's called it's a
signature ride in California Adventure
it's called soaring over California have
you been who's been who's seen this
anybody have you good okay
this sweet says this well this is my
interpretation he doesn't say this I
think this is the essence of experience
okay so what what Disney does is they
put you in these these things they lift
you up off the floor and it's like
you're hang gliding over California okay
and so you see all these images of
California all right so there's
wonderful music audition I'll play it
for you so you can hear it
so you're going over you know Northern
California the rivers etc you end up
moving from there you go into these
beautiful beautiful parts of North
Carolina with hot air balloons your
soaring etc as you as you as the vehicle
tips you down the wind speed in the
theater increases so it blows your hair
okay and you move this way in that way
etc when you go over a big sir what
happens in the theater they squirt water
in to the seat so you feel water okay
and you smell they they insert the smell
of salt into the theater okay then you
go over the Sierra Nevadas and you're
skiing the temperature in the theatre
drops okay and you go over this I mean
this is all experiential in a moment
you'll go over orange groves in the
Imperial Valley of California when you
go over the orange groves wet they
insert the smell of oranges in the
theater okay so um I've quantified I
push then Lin and I have talked about
this I think experiential means you
engage more than one sense at a time I
think that's the essence of experience I
think our young people are yearning for
an experience of Jesus and the way you
get that is by engaging more than one
sense at a time what's the problem with
most of our worship okay it's boring it
is boring because we only engage
typically what sense hearing okay
and in the neuroscience right now in the
brain wishers which is just rocking my
world in the neuroscience in terms of
brain activity of the senses the one
that engages the least amount of brain
power hearing audition the one that
engages the most brain power this is in
functional magnetic resonance imaging
that we can do for the first time only
seven years ago
no visual it's seeing smell thank you
all factory is the strongest remember
sense because it's the only one that
doesn't have to go through the amygdala
which is the gatekeeper for memory okay
that's why smell is so important but in
terms of actual brain engagement seeing
is the most all right
so think about ministry with young
people as experiential ways you engage
more than one sense at a time
simultaneously and young people seem to
walk out saying I get Jesus because
you've engaged more than one sense so
one of my students and you know this is
a call from the Holy Spirit because she
used to be an Imagineer in Pasadena in
Anaheim and she left that to come to
seminary I'm like you messed up in a big
way you had the best job in the whole
wide world in your kind of seminary
stupid girl anyway um she said she
actually worked I talked about this in
class and she actually worked on soaring
over California
development of it and she's and she
pulled me aside afterwards and said
professor you know I worked on soar I
said did you cheat goes yeah it was
great and I said well I'm intrigued
tell me about it and she goes well we
you know we got sound because you hear
music etc we got touch because you feel
the wind and you feel the spray we got
smell because the oranges and the salt
etc and we got this idea of seeing
because you see everything okay and of
course it ends at Disneyland the
happiest place on earth
okay I said but you're missing the last
one and she said I know we worked on
that for a year and a half I said taste
really and she goes oh yeah we worked on
it for a year and a half and we couldn't
get it because she said we would we
tried giving people out candy when they
would walk in and something to put in
their mouths for taste and ice and she
says was a complete straight face and I
said what happened and she goes we
discovered people have totally different
suck factors
and I said it took you a year and a half
to find out that people have different
suck factors I guys won't do that today
okay and she said she's up she's not
good just like okay okay fine I'm like
you need to get a sense of humor
anyway but she said Disney which is
doing some of the best attention span
research in the country they're trying
to figure out what they have to do to
keep people's attention on a ride okay
and where and what they're saying
experiential is engaging more than one
sense at a time participatory you and I
live in a participatory age our young
people expect to be able to participate
the UN expect to be spectators they
expect to be able to participate so this
is Tahrir Square this started remember
with whom teenagers youth college
students and high school students
secondary students all their lives all
they knew was martial law under US
supported President Mubarak okay over 42
years of martial law their whole lives
the first night apparently the word is
about 63 high school secondary students
and college students gathered in the
Tahrir Square in the heart of Cairo most
populous Arab nation in the world and to
Mubarak s-- credit or disillusionment
they didn't push them out they were
there for four days on the fifth day
there were over 700 of them there
remember what happened on the sixth day
do you call thugs came in that we found
out later were hired by the government
and dressed down and they came in on
camels and cars and the and three people
died that night okay
the next day you don't remember what
happened who came for the first time to
the square grandparents actually it was
older adults and there was an interview
that I have that I loved
older adult man speaking in Arabic a
grandparent and they asked him this is
this was on al-jazeera in English they
asked him why did you come and the
translation says he says because they
were beating my grandchildren he said at
first I thought oh these are just kids
the government will soon dispense with
them but then I saw that they were
beating my grandchildren I'm an old man
they can kill me but they cannot kill my
grandchildren the next day then who came
parents came grandparents parents
children were in the square 23 days 23
days the regime ended 23 days this is
the participatory time social networking
allows that to happen this is a
participatory time third issue imagistic
the expectation is that there would be
the opportunity to see things engage as
much of the part of the brain as
possible sweets says it's a marvelous
quote sweets says the shift is from a
culture of the page to a culture of the
screen sweet also says the problem is
any institution that has achieved the
highest expression of a given medium has
the most difficult time changing when
the next medium comes along we are the
Church of Jesus Christ
we love the page I teach at a graduate
school in theology
I love the page I got a PhD based upon
the page ok and now we're being told to
shift to the screen it's a huge huge
shift and we are resistant the Church of
Jesus Christ perhaps most of all
Gutenberg Bibles I mean come on we are
the people of the page we get this
we're an imagistic age last one we are
in a communal age knowing is constructed
so I believe we are in a constructivist
society now where we're knowing Jesus
knowing God knowing the church knowing
the Holy Spirit knowing God's activity
in the world it is not up to any one
person knowing now is constructed
Wikipedia which by the way is not an
adequate citation for a scholarly paper
my students are like I got it from
Wikipedia I gave you a citation like
that is not a citation Dean is that
correct it's not a citation thank you
very much I'm gonna tell the Dean I like
this Dean Dean Britton thank you very
much you just ruined my whole person
that's checks on it I want give me the
source at the bottom don't give me the
webpage site okay but but I think we're
in a wiki world I think we do wiki
theology I think we understand this are
young people they're not buying two
years ago for the first time we had more
online downloads for music than CDs
because they're not gonna listen to
somebody else's idea of an album they're
going to they're gonna make their own
they're gonna create their own knowledge
is being constructed in this day and age
if you think there's resonance I love
this about the Lord if you think there's
resonance to the to the church
liberation theology church member in the
base communities when these Roman
Catholic priests begin to think golly
even these chlorin quote uneducated
peasants these farmers if I just read
the scripture to them and turn to them
and say what do you think this means and
they begin to say in their own words in
their own context I think this is what
the Lord saying to us through this text
that began this whole movement of
socially constructed understandings of
how God is speaking to us through
Scripture in these days and initially
the Roman Church was threatened by that
which is typical of any power structure
these people though even
degrees how can they speak with
integrity about the Scriptures and yet
these liberation theology these base
communities
is set us on fire throughout the entire
world young people are in the same mode
they know things that you and I do not
know they understand God in ways that I
do not understand God
so in all humility and with the grace of
God and by the mercies of God I depend
upon them to help me know what it is God
is calling me and us to do in these days
it's this posture that I think we're
being called to it's an epic posture
experiential participatory imagistic and
communal okay I've given you I've thrown
stuff at you and I'm mindful that this
isn't as imagistic as I would like it to
be nor is it as communal or as
participatory I also like it to be but
I'm grateful to you for the precious
gift of your time